hey leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal wir in einer
zufallsgenerierte welt in minecraft eure
ersten diamanten innerhalb von nur fünf
minuten findet dafür erstelle ich mir
mal eben eine neue welt wie ihr gesehen
habt habe ich keinen zieht ein gegeben
das ist einfach aus dem grund damit ihr
nicht vorwerfen könnte der hatten zieht
genommen den hat er vorher schon mal
benutzten hat da vorher schon geguckt
oder diamanten sind
das ist alles komplett random hier so
was ich als erstes mache ist dass ich
mir holz hole das ist dabei ist es egal
welches holz das ist das kann diese
reiche hier sein das kann auch dieses
braune holz sein das ist komplett egal
ihr könnt euch vier holz holen es wäre
aber besser wenn ihr euch fünf holz holt
das ist einfach sicherer wenn ihr
nachher noch mehr sticks braucht und da
wären wir dann auch schon beim zweiter
aber der zweite sache ihr macht euch
erstmal eine workbench und zwölf stocker
denn die brauchen wir nachher so die
workbench setzt sich jetzt einfach mal
irgendwo ab die setzen einfach hier ab
und ich mache mir jetzt eine stein
schaufel und eine stein spitzhacke die
workbench kommt natürlich auch mit so
und jetzt liegt es an euch ihr könnt
euch jetzt irgendeinen ort in eurer
minecraft welt suchen an dem ihr euch
einfach in der erde graben wollte ich
könnte mich natürlich jetzt auch schon
hier in der erde graben oder hier oder
hier oder auch hier aber für mich wie
diese welt einfach nicht danach aus dass
hier drunter höhlensysteme sind daher in
der nähe keine berge sind also wenn ihr
berge seht euch am besten neben einem
werk in den boden dass es immer am
sichersten
wie schon gesagt das ist eine
zufallsgenerierte welt nicht dass er
denkt er hat sich vorher den ort schon
ausgeguckt also das ist alles komplett
zufallsgenerierte hier wächst auch gut
aus niemand ist ein berg hier schon ein
bisschen tiefer gelegen ich glaube mich
einfach mal hier runter so dann hole ich
mir noch ein paar steine hier damit ich
mir bessere werkzeuge machen kann
dafür hab ich jetzt einfach hoch
platziert die workbench eben unter mich
unter mir und mache mir die gleichen
sachen die am anfang nur noch mal in
stein das ist einfach dafür ja keine
ahnung werden auch mit holz weiter
graben können aber dann dauert natürlich
länger
was ich jetzt mache ist nicht unbedingt
notwendig empfehle ich euch aber da
sicherer ist und einfach nur wegen der
vorsicht mache ich das ich habe mich
nämlich zwei blöcke immer runter weil
wenn ihr euch nur ein blog runter kraft
wissen nicht was unter euch ist deswegen
kann es sein dass zwischendurch einfach
und leise kommt und ich glaube jetzt
einfach mal so lang und habe sich kohl
oder eisen finde oder eine höhle und da
ist auch schon die erste kohle
ich nehme die kohle mit so dass noch
mehr kohle 32 34 56 kein bock mehr zu
zählen das ist viel zu viel also das
natürlich sehr gut wenn ihr direkt kohle
findet müsst ihr nicht unbedingt findet
man bestimmt auch noch unten aber ist
natürlich gut wenn jetzt findet nehmen
wir natürlich auch alles mit brauchen
wir später
und ja ich glaube ich übertreibe grad
ein bisschen aber egal so wir graben uns
weiter unter und jetzt kommen ein paar
lex warum weiß ich nicht aber egal ich
lasse mich dadurch einfach mal nicht
beeindrucken und gab mich hier weiter
nach unten
wie gesagt ich hoffe einfach dass ich
gleich auf eine höhle stoße bzw
aufweisen bzw direkt schon einen
diamanten finde das halte ich zwar für
unrealistisch da die diamanten meist
erst auf der höhe
15 beziehungsweise 16 kommen aber ich
bin ja guten mutes als solche grad mich
einfach weiter in die tiefe bis sich auf
ein höhlensystem schloss wenn ich auf 15
beziehungsweise 16 bin und auch keine
höhle gefunden werde ich mich einfach in
die seite graben aber eigentlich stößt
man auf höhere 15 oder 16 immer auf eine
höhle und
haben auch schon den ersten song gehört
das heißt hier direkt nebenan muss eine
höhle sein und da haben wir auch schon
den laacher see gefunden und wie ich das
werden erkennen kann ist dass wir hätten
sogar ein mops warner
ja weil da ist da ist cobblestone und
cobblestone deutet darauf hin dass ein
mops potter ist das seht ihr da jetzt
daher kommen wahrscheinlich auch die
zombies ich versuche mir erstmal ein
lover ein weg über die firma hierzu
banden und wir sicherlich merkt ist das
hier nachsynchronisiert herzlichen
glückwunsch und die die schon am anfang
gemerkt haben ich dachte eigentlich ich
sag's er es nicht aber das schon
redstone doch deswegen sind wir nicht
hier versuchen nämlich diamanten noch
die zombies hinter schrecklich und wie
gesagt ich verspreche euch nicht dass
diese dass das geklappt was ich hier
sage also das muss nicht unbedingt
klappen
bei mir hat es bisher fast immer
geklappt ich versuche mir jetzt einfach
mal bei diesen dabei blick herüber zu
bauen und da haben wir auch schon den
ersten jemanden gefunden
das heißt der keiner stoppt jetzt
einfach mal das heißt nämlich in dem
video auch dass ich zeige die man die
diamanten findet nicht wie man sie ab
das heißt ihr müsst ihr jetzt bevor er
den diamanten abbauen könnt euch noch
eine eisen spitzhacke machen und da sind
auch gleich drei diamanten also ihr habt
gesehen das geht ziemlich schnell
diamanten zu finden mit diesem trick ich
hoffe ihr habt euch das video angeschaut
und wissen jetzt ungefähr wie ich das
mache dass ich mich schnell diamanten
finde
und ich sage einfach mal tschüss bis zum
nächsten video
[Musik]